The robots are coming.
We all know it.
And yet here we are, marching
towards doom with smiles
on our faces.
Hey, future extinct humans--
Trace here with some robot news
from Planet Earth.
Robots are stealing
our jobs, man.
We talked about this before,
but that was more abstract.
Now, with Amazon planning
to ship via drone,
Google is on the
robotic bandwagon, too.
The search giant acquired
seven robotics companies,
and put the man
who was previously
on top of the Android
operating system-- Andy
Rubin-- in charge.
Look at the self-driving car.
Google took the human driver
out of the equation entirely,
and now they're thinking
of doing something similar
with jobs like shipping,
grocery stock, manufacturing,
and other low skilled jobs.
Rubin believes robotics
have advanced enough
where we can build hands
and bodies pretty easily--
it's the software
and sensors that
need to have some breakthroughs.
Robots have already been
adopted in auto manufacturing
and military application--
and if Amazon has their way,
drones will be shipping
packages before you know it.
For the moment, our grocery
jobs, retail positions,
and food service jobs might
be safe, but only just.
But if you're a security guard,
you're about to be under-bid.
The five foot tall, 300
pound K5 Autonomous Data
Machine is the first useful
robotic security guard.
We're not jumping to a
RoboCop dystopia quite yet.
But seriously-- a robot
that guards humans?
This little guy sort
of looks like R2-D2,
and is described as a 21st
century neighborhood watchman.
It can't attack,
but it can record
what's happening-- it
just kind of watches.
As it's a work in
progress, they've not yet
added facial recognition or
other things it should probably
have to effectively police.
The K5 project was built
to protect schoolchildren
after the Sandy Hook
shootings, and it
does so for less
than minimum wage--
costing only about
$6.25 per hour.
Which begs the question-- do
robots deserve minimum wage?
While you think
about that, there
are plenty of other
robots looking
to take over lower
wage jobs, too.
Sex workers are legal in
some parts of the world.
And now a robot can--
you know-- perform
some handy tasks for you.
It was made in Japan-- and
paired with virtual reality,
it syncs with its
rhythm, and-- yeah.
For now, the only
major advantage
we have in this battle
is the old noodle.
Low education, repetitive
jobs are slowly
being taken over by robots.
And by slowly, I mean, like,
in the conceivable future.
Unlike some of the more
loosey-goosey projects
that Google tackles,
this robotics plan
is hoping to have breakthroughs
and make sales pretty soon.
They've got the will--
they've got the cash.
Let's just hope they build
in the three laws of robotics
alongside their slogan,
"Don't be evil."
What do you think?
Do you want robots to take
over some or all of these jobs?
Should we protect humans
from their cold metal grip?
Let us know your thoughts
in the comments below.
And just so you know
it's not all bad,
some robots are making
mankind better--
like the ones that make beer.
Our friends over at
Brew Age got the scoop
on a San Francisco
brewery using robotic arms
to do their dirty work.
If you're a beer geek,
check out the video--
it's at YouTube.Com/brewageTV,
and you can subscribe to them.
But don't forget to subscribe
here, too, for more DNews.